Keith Jordan is a gender critical
campaigner who wants to stop medical
intervention for Trans teenagers it's a
deeply contentious area and he claims
his views prompted metrobank to refuse
him a business account this seems to be
a plague at the moment of chemistically
motivated decisions in Banks there are a
huge risk to individual liberty because
if you deprive someone of the ability to
bank and
you are depriving them of their Liberty
ultimately because you need
a bank account to function properly in
society metrobank denies that a client's
politics or personal beliefs influence
its decisions but the issue has been
highlighted by former ukip leader Nigel
farage the television presenter alleges
his account with coot was closed because
of his politics
banks are required to do additional
checks on the accounts of what are known
as politically exposed persons that's
politicians their families or the
politically active because there may be
a greater risk of blackmail or money
laundering now the government has asked
the financial conduct Authority based
here to have a look at how those rules
are being applied in practice
what about political vetting are you
vetting customers thank you
bank boss is heading to discuss savings
rates with the regulator we're reluctant
to discuss the issue but the Sea's
consumer Chief says they have to strike
a balance
Democratic Society your political views
um are your own where one needs to think
about in terms of any service provision
is how that engagement is between a
customer and an institution the
politically exposed person's rules
affect only a few thousand people but
some of those impacted complain they're
far too intrusive the banks are being
utterly disingenuous about this I think
the banks are taking the path of least
resistance which is the minute you're a
pet uh they simply either refuse to give
you a bank account or financial services
or they send you Reams and reams of
forms a very detailed and very intrusive
analysis of your financial affairs the
FCA will report back to the chancellor
in the coming weeks Paul Kelso Sky News